well as it stands right now the election
results as we are told are still
trickling in uh quote unquote
Republicans are inching closer towards a
slim majority in the house while the
Senate still hangs in the balance the
senate race is in a few key states have
yet to be called now two days later why
is it taking this long I mean how is it
that a state in a modern and allegedly
Advanced country could take two days to
count its ballots and still not be
finished
how do we explain a state that has you
know a 60 percent counted of its votes
and then you check back 18 hours later
and they've counted 75 percent of their
votes how could this slow pace possibly
be justified especially when States like
Florida with far more ballots to count
managed to get them all tallied in like
five hours
well it makes sense once you understand
the process and I think a lot of people
don't understand the process there's a
lot of misinformation so in in Arizona
for example
takes a long time in Arizona but what
happens is each individual ballot has to
be ferried up a Mountainside on the back
of a goat and delivered to a magical
Oracle who's sitting in a cave who then
communicates the results via a chain of
smoke signals which eventually get back
to the election office which then after
any necessary Corrections are made of
course sends the tally to CNN by carrier
pigeon so that's the system and it's
quite standard I mean how else are they
supposed to do it can you think of a
better one
at least that's the the most encouraging
theory that I can come up with because
the more likely explanation is that they
take so long because they want to take
so long and there is no good reason why
they could want that I mean there are
reasons why they could want it but no
good ones
they don't fix the system because for
their purpose the system isn't broken
it's working exactly as they prefer
according to their purposes
yet even as we wait for the Mountaintop
Oracle to give us the final results we
can we can still arrive at certain
conclusions about the state of our
country and our culture and none of them
are
all that encouraging I'm afraid so take
Montana referendum number 131 the
results here too are still being
tabulated somehow but with 90 reporting
or so it looks certain that the
referendum is going to fail in Montana
nearly a quarter of a million residents
voted against the referendum with about
200 000 voting for it
what does the referendum seek to
accomplish well
it is supposed to guarantee medical
treatment for infants born alive after a
botched abortion
so to be clear a majority of Voters in
Montana do not want to give life-saving
medical treatment to a born infant
outside of the mother's womb they voted
in favor of leaving the child to die
horrifically and painfully
now there are some generous Souls out
there who want to make excuses for these
voters claiming the referendum was
worded in a confusing way
and that can be a problem certainly and
has been in the past with uh you know
there's a referendum and then you look
at the way it's worded and it's it's
hard in fact we had one of those a
couple months ago we were looking at it
and it's just it's hard to tell where
what they're asking you
but you tell me if you're confused by
this here's the actual language here's
the question that appeared on the ballot
Montana this is what it said
an act adopting the born alive infant
protection act providing that infants
born alive including infants born alive
after an abortion are legal persons
requiring Health Care Providers to take
necessary actions to preserve the life
of a born alive infant providing a
penalty providing that the proposed act
be submitted to qualified electors of
Montana and providing an effective date
and any voters were invited to vote
either yes approving the referendum or
no to rejecting it in these are
statements it's an act providing legal
protection to infants born alive yes or
no
I can't see how anyone could possibly be
confused by that
again an act to provide legal status to
infants born alive after abortion yes
you want to give them that status and
thus save their lives or no you don't
and if you say no as it clearly
indicates in the wording you are voting
to deny legal protections to Born infant
children
a majority of Voters in Montana Montana
okay not typically considered a Bastion
of far-left activism
voted to deny those protections to
children
we can Comfort ourselves with the
desperate hope that these Montana voters
are just incredibly stupid rather than
incredibly evil but I think that would
be a false hope
in fact abortion and infanticide won on
the ballot all across the country in red
States and blue States voters from
Montana to Kentucky
to more expected places like Michigan
and California voted Often by
considerable margins to deny any legal
protections to children born and unborn
that's the fact of the matter
it's not fun to consider but it is a
fact all the same
there there is definitely we cannot deny
a candidate quality problem in the
Republican party but there is also I'm
afraid to say
a voter quality problem
well if you feel like you still aren't
getting the respect you deserve in your
life established titles is the way to go
it's your way and opportunity to earn
the title of Lord or lady and gain the
respect that you deserve all you need is
a one square foot plot of land in
Scotland established titles is a Project
based on a historic Scottish customer
landowners are referred to as lairds or
Lords and Ladies in English in your
title pack you will be bestowed with at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate in Edelson Scotland
plus an official certificate as you can
see that I have here with a Crest that
comes with it your certificate features
a unique plot Number with which you can
see the exact location of your uh of
your plot title packs from established
titles are a fun and unique gift for any
occasion there are even couple packs
that come with adjoining plots of land
for that special someone in your life
with your certificate you can officially
add the prefix of Lord or lady to your
credit cards your plane ticket and even
your dating profile established titles
told me that the first 200 people to
purchase a title pack using my exclusive
link will receive a plot within walking
distance of my line so depending on how
many people sign up we could become a
you know our own kingdom established
titles is actually running a massive
sale right now and if you use the code
wall should check out you'll get an
additional 10 off so go to established
titles.com Walsh to get your gifts now
and help support the channel
now the results of these referendums and
of the races themselves can largely be
explained by and uh blamed on I suppose
too often overlapping groups and that
would be gen Z and unmarried women
now it's been widely discussed and as
comes as a surprise to know and I assume
that Democrats won the Gen Z vote by
about two to one
but the unmarried woman factor is I
think most notable as a daily wire
reports quote unmarried women voted
Democrat in the 2022 midterm elections
by a significant margin according to
exit poll data compared to married
individuals favoring GOP candidates this
year a CNN exit poll of 18 571 total
respondents found 68 of single women
mark their ballots for Democratic
politicians a 37 point margin over the
Republican Party Republicans gained 20
more votes from married men than
Democrats while single men voted seven
percent more for GOP figures we should
also note importantly that Republicans
won the married woman vote by 14 points
so Republicans win clear majorities of
the married vote and still a slim
majority of the married men of the
rather unmarried man vote
but unmarried women swing heavily to
Democrats
based on this we can also assume that
they are largely responsible for these
ballot measures and shrining abortion
and infanticide across the country I
mean that's why these that's why these
measures passed or didn't pass as the
case may be
um the good news for for you know
Democrats is that the number of
unmarried women in the country continues
to increase year over year
in the middle of the previous Century so
around 1940 1950 a vast majority of the
households in the country 80 or so were
comprised of married couples and
families they were led by married
couples or families you know 80 percent
that number fell to around half by the
end of the century so around 2000 we
were about 50 percent of uh households
were led by married couples and within a
decade after that around 2020 it felt
2010 it fell to less than half
so now a majority of households are not
led by married couples and this is a
this is a first in in recorded history
and the trend continues rapidly in that
direction every year
this is very bad news for children and
not just because unmarried people are
more likely to vote to strip children of
basic legal protections but also because
the children born to these unmarried
people remember we're talking about
unmarried people not not necessarily
childless people
I'm not exclusively childless so any
children born to these unmarried people
by by every conceivable measure face
greater obstacles okay they'll have a
worse time of it they will fare worse
children born to single parents are far
more likely to have behavior problems
far more likely to have academic
problems far more likely to drop out of
school far more likely to get expelled
far more likely to end up in prison far
more likely to end up on drugs far more
likely to end up homeless far more
likely to fall victim to violent crime
on and on and on
it is extremely bad for children and for
society to abandon marriage
that's just the fact
but as is so often the case what is bad
for kids and bad for the culture is
really good for the Democrats
you know they are the Democrat Party is
a it's a vulture you know it feasts on
the carcass of uh decaying civilizations
now it's easy to see why the Democrat
Party is determined then to undermine
marriage and destroy the nuclear family
you can see why the left is openly
hostile to the nuclear family why they
have declared war against it
the nuclear family led by man and woman
bonded in marriage serves as a blockade
a fortress standing against the left's
political and cultural aspirations they
know they can't achieve their ultimate
ends without blowing up the Fortress and
that's what they've set out to do and
they're already having you know enormous
success and they're reaping enormous
political rewards in the process
now why do
unmarried people especially women tend
to favor Democrats that's obvious enough
marriage and family life will tend to
make you less selfish tend to make you
less obsessively focused on your own
desires tend to make you more invested
in the future more grounded right in a
word more conservative
selfish shallow people will naturally
find leftism more appealing and they're
also more susceptible to manipulation
what's more when you're single you're
more vulnerable and that's more likely
to be dependent on the government
Democrats know this which is one of the
primary reasons they oppose a nuclear
family nuclear families need less from
the government typically and and uh and
therefore are harder to control the more
Reliant you are on the government the
more you can be controlled
the easier it is for the Democrats to
extract your vote
unmarried women in particular if they're
sexually active
you know are going to be more likely you
could the Democrats can get their vote
manipulate them use emotional blackmail
to get their vote with with the abortion
issue
because they're more vulnerable and
because they're not married if they have
a kid uh they're more likely to see it
as a as a crisis you know because
they're not married now when you're
married and there are still married
couples that get abortions which is
hideously evil of course but um
if you're married and you have a kid
you're less likely to see it as a crisis
because you're married and you have a
family and that's what that's what the
marriage this is this is what that's all
about
so what does this mean it means of
course that our political problem is
first a cultural problem
and there is no solving the former
without addressing the latter
and there is no addressing the latter if
we're going to neglect marriage and the
family
you know for decades conservatives have
looked for ways to win the political
game without winning the cultural game
and and they're looking for ways to win
the culture then without defending and
encouraging marriage in the family and
it just doesn't work it can't it never
will
if we want the cultural victory and thus
the political victory
our message should be
get married have kids
stay married
get married have kids stay married in
that order that's the three-step process
get married have kids stay married
more people follow that yes Republicans
will win many more elections
you know if we were still at 80 percent
married households then Republicans
would never lose a national election
again
but more importantly
we will have saved our culture from
Annihilation and more important still
people will be living purposeful joyful
lives
which ultimately is the end result the
Democrats are most desperate to avoid
and I'll do it for us for this course in
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]